good evening everyone
i'm councillor simon wooten leader of
rochford district council
i'm pleased to open this virtual webinar
public engagement session
which will focus predominantly on the
rochford pre-application part of the
council's asset
delivery program can i extend a warm
welcome to members of the public
who have given their time to join us
this evening
although it feels very different to a
physical meeting we've become used to
virtually
working over many months so in the
circumstances
this is the best medium possible
i'm pleased to introduce mike davis
chairman of rady town museum management
group
who will be chairing this evening's
meeting
i'm really grateful to him for giving up
his time and the interest he is showing
in the council's asset
development programme mike is a
long-standing
and very well-respected resident within
the district
and he is passionate about the community
and heritage
across the district but particularly in
rayleigh
i'm delighted that so many people have
joined the webinar
you are invited to ask questions using
the web chat facility
at long last it is a pleasure to be able
to discuss the plans
and sharing the vision i emphasize
however
that they are just plans at present so
feedback
is not just welcomed but vital to help
shape
the final plans we want to hear what
people think
the meeting will be recorded and shared
for those who are unable to attend
and at this point i'd like to hand over
if i may to mike
davis mike over to you
thank you my thanks to councillor simon
wooten the leader of rocha district
council for that most
generous introduction
we have a number of presentations this
evening in this first
of two such webinars relating to the six
sites across rochford
as part of the rocha district council
asset delivery program
tonight we are going to concentrate on
the rochford plans
whilst on the 17th of march please make
a note in your diaries
we are then going to concentrate on the
plans for the rayleigh sites
however it is important to note that all
six sites are part of the overall
package
so we are happy to take questions on any
aspect relating to the whole project
all questions and the responses will be
available to view
on both the rdc website and please feel
free
to ask any relevant questions whether in
support or not
of these proposals you are welcome to
submit
questions during this presentation or
indeed afterwards and similarly for the
regular presentation
this webinar is being recorded and will
be available on the rdc
and voyage websites it is planned that
this presentation will take
in the region of one hour
i will now introduce the panel who will
be presenting the detailed information
and who will then give responses to the
questions
we have already received to date and any
others
that we receive this evening first i
would like to welcome and introduce
angela hutchins who is the axing
managing director for the rochford
district council
we have matt harwood white now matt is
the assistant director for
assets and commercial for rocha district
council
and the senior officer responsible for
this
asset delivery program
i'd now like to introduce george farley
to you
george is from gb partnership and is the
program director
for the voyage program gb partnership
are the private sector delivery partner
selected by
rdc under a competitive tendering
process
to lead on the voyage program
specialise in public sector partnerships
and development programs and finally i'd
like to introduce
peter bust to you peter is from purcell
architects and is the lead architect
for the program angela will now speak on
the background to this asset delivery
program
the project to date how you can
contribute with your views ahead of the
final plans
have your say and the website and how
all six sites dovetail
into the overall plan angela i'll pass
on to you
thank you very much mike so
by background we first began this
conversation internally
when we were discussing what to do with
the two event sites which were at the
time within the council's leisure
contract
with fusion lifestyle so that's the
freight house in rochford town
and the mill arts and event center in
rayleigh
we already knew that event sites were
becoming a bit of a financial problem
for councils across the country
and for us 20 years ago when the leisure
contract was first let
they were the mainstay of weddings
parties and entertainment
but over the last two decades that
market has changed
and more and more venues are available
for public hire
and with better facilities the me the
freight house and the mill hall
were looking pretty tired and was
struggling to compete in that
marketplace where
and were on economic to run
so we looked at then at the rest of our
real estate uh owned by the council
um predominantly the civic suite israeli
and the council's offices
in rochford and we noticed a number of
recurring themes
primarily they were all aging buildings
which were in need of significant
updating
not just in terms of bricks and mortar
but also in terms of electrics
mechanics and technical to bring them up
to modern standards
things like broadband wi-fi projection
equipment for example
they were expensive to heat to light to
operate and maintain
and they were particularly limited with
opportunities to green
and become more environmentally sound
they were also heritage sites which
limited the scope for widespread
updating
and they didn't work as modern spaces
for example
the porter cabin reception at south
street is cramped and unwelcoming
and the great eastern room in the
freight house is uh troubling
if you uh acoustically if you want to
use it as a large space
we also noticed that the sites were
underutilized for their space
that didn't mean that they weren't well
used but it meant that they were too big
and unsuitable for most of their users
so a large performance space was very
often used by a group that's probably
about a
fifth of the size that the room could
actually accommodate
there were more singular desk spaces
than we needed at south street
but not enough meeting rooms or
collaborative spaces
and the fixed furniture of the council
chamber was so restrictive
that it's virtually impossible to use
that space other than for council
meetings i know the rest of the time
the room sits empty
the horrible space at freight house and
mill hall was limited and
as i say often too big or too small for
most ordinary events
so booking capacity was limited and the
commercial model therefore was
uneconomic
he did some work to look at our options
for reconfiguring that estate
and that was the obc the outline
business case that we presented to
council back in january 2019
so two years ago that that document
looked at a number of options
but the bottom line was that doing
nothing was not an option
it would be more expensive to do the
basic maintenance and repair
than to actually reconfigure the whole
estate and do something new with our
buildings
we wanted to take the value from all six
sites within the program
and reinvest them to create a cost
neutral
civic space which would be a legacy for
the future and which residents could be
proud
members identified that they wanted a
new community centre for rayleigh
and so we agreed a model which would
invest additional spend in that site
to get something really special but it
was important to us that it should be a
community centre
not an events center an event center is
relying on a commercial operating model
to fund it
what we wanted is a space for the
community to use with a not-for-profit
ethos
we wanted to create a space which would
maximize use by the community
and which would also house our partners
ravs citizens advice
and oaks you have the next slide please
yes
so the council identified a solution
which it believed was its preferred
option
and following that procurement process
that mike mentioned earlier
we identify gb partnerships as our
development partner
and working with gp partnerships we want
to create civic buildings which are
environmentally and financially
sustainable for the future
maintain community facilities in
rochford and in rayleigh
maintain accommodation for our partners
in rochford and
in rayleigh and are true to our heritage
settings
creating 21st century civic spaces
with state-of-the-art technology to
proof their use
for the community and for a legacy so a
lot of work has been
gone into to get the project to this
state to enable us
to share something with you which is
more than just conceptual
to provide you with sufficient detail to
ask questions
to understand the proposals and to offer
feedback
but i want to remind everybody that no
planning application
has yet been submitted and no formal
council decision has yet been taken to
proceed
so when we say that we are asking for
your feedback to help shape the next
stage of the project
we mean it grab the next slide please
as it says on the slide the information
we're sharing tonight
is a snapshot of the planning
submissions which we're putting together
to give you an idea of how our plans are
progressing
they've been through the rigor of
working with planning
uh colleagues and are on policy or above
policy and so we know that they are
buildable
and we know that the work has been done
to make sure that they are achievable
tonight we're focusing on the rochford
sites and next month we'll look at the
rayleigh ones
but i do want to make the point that the
funding of all of the new civic
buildings is only possible
because of the whole program approach
that we're taking these are not
individual sites this is one program
which cross-funds itself save for the
additional cash injection for the new
community centre
can i have the next slide please
so we will do all this over again on the
17th of march when we will be
specifically addressing the rayleigh
sites
and as mike says that doesn't mean you
can't ask questions
about that tonight but because we are
because we are taking a program approach
so of course it's relevant
but please be assured that we will
specifically focus on the rayleigh sites
and in particular
the mills hall next month
thank you mike
good thank you angela i'm now going to
hand over to peter buist
who's going to give our next
presentation and he's going to give
specific details of the designs
the core principles and the importance
of our heritage
relation to each of the three rochford
sites in what will be
the longest presentation this evening
over to peter thank you
thanks mike so good evening yes my name
is peter buist
and i'm an architect from purcell
we are a practice of architects master
planners and heritage consultants
and we specialize in working with
buildings and sites that have
conservation
and heritage constraints we've been
working with gb partnerships
and rochefort district council for
approximately 18 months
analyzing and understanding the existing
sites
and developing outline proposals for
their future
whilst i'm an architect i am presenting
on behalf of a team of consultants that
have been engaged on these projects
including many specialists such as civil
structural
and building service engineers heritage
consultants
tree specialists and ecologists
i'll now provide an overview of the work
that we have undertaken to date
across the three sites in rochford
including the project objectives
the opportunities and constraints of
each site and the principles of our
concept
designs the designs on each of the sites
are at an early stage of development
where we have established outline
concept proposals
i'll start with the freight house and
then move on to 3-15 south street
and finish with number 57 south street
so starting with the freight house the
freight house is to become a brand new
civic and community hub representing a
forward-thinking
21st century council set upon the
foundations of a rich
and proud history next slide please
this new community hub will serve the
communities of rochford
and the surrounding district delivering
administrative
civic and operational services within a
welcoming accessible
customer focused and safe environment
the existing building offers a wonderful
opportunity to create a facility
that reflects the rich history of
rochefort through its sensitive adaption
and extension we can also create a
sustainable
efficient and modern building that fills
the community's expectations of the
council's services
the freight house will continue to
provide versatile and flexible space
for many community public and private
events
indeed the three existing function rooms
will be modernized in order to best
cater
for the wide variety of local events
next slide please
next slide thanks the freight house is a
lake victorian
red brick building with a sloping roof
and projecting bays to the west
elevation
that mark out the various entrances to
the building
the freight house lies along a north to
south line and is a large building that
sits
on top of the grass bank that looks onto
bradley way
bradley way is a busy road into and
around rochford and therefore the
freight house
is highly visible to those coming in and
out of the town
whilst its industrial heritage is still
clearly evident in its external
appearance
and the internal plan arrangement there
have been some less sensitive
adaptions and additions over the last 40
years
our proposed refurbishment of the
building is an opportunity to rectify
these late
20th century alterations with more
sensitive changes
next slide please
located opposite the railway station and
above the busy road the freight house is
a gateway site
for rochford it is locally listed and
located within the rochford conservation
area
proposals must therefore be sensitive to
both the building itself
and the historic character of its
surroundings
to the east is rockford reservoir
creating a wonderful setting for the
building
and an opportunity for public and civic
events to spill out
into the adjacent parkland
the building itself is sunken below the
level of the car park that surrounds it
to the north west and south conversely
a steep grass bank drops down from the
building's east elevation
to meet the parkland and footpath that
goes around the reservoir
next slide please
thanks to accommodate the council's
brief
the existing freight house needs to be
extended
we explored a number of options for the
form location
and size of the extension these included
new extensions to the north west and
south of the existing building
locating the extension to the south of
the site allows the historic freight
house to remain visible from bradley way
and maintains the important link with
the railway station
the extension will also benefit from
being close to the reservoir
and parkland to the east
through a new master plan for the site
the project is an opportunity to improve
the immediate setting of the freight
house
which benefits accessibility and
functionality
next slide please
the proposed new extension will be two
stories high
and has many similarities to the
existing building
the new extension will accommodate the
council's administrative functions
office spaces meeting rooms and breakout
areas are located across the ground and
first floors
and will be flexible providing various
types of working areas for individuals
and groups enclosed meeting pods will be
provided for more sensitive and
confidential meetings
an open double height atrium allows
people to move about the extension
with informal social breakout spaces and
lovely views over the nearby parkland
trees and reservoir a new lift
will ensure the building is fully
accessible to all staff
visitors and public
a glazed atrium separates the new
extension from the existing freight
house building
clearly defining the new and old
elements of the building
this glazed atrium will be the new
public entrance
providing a wonderful arrival space
which will make it easy to find your way
around
the existing freight house will
accommodate the civic functions
with a new council chamber being created
within the large central hall
when not required the chamber will be
dismantled and stored
to enable the large hall and the other
two function rooms to be used
for many other public and private events
the function rooms will be supported by
modern kitchen and catering facilities
bars and servers and secure storage will
also be provided
the function rooms will be enhanced to
control sound so that they best
accommodate the wide variety of uses
as well as stopping noise coming out of
the building during louder evening
functions
each function space is independently
accessed so that events can be held at
the same time
without disturbing each other
next slide please
so in in summary the proposal is
approximately double the overall gross
internal area of the freight house
albeit the footprint of the new
extension is smaller
due to the more efficient use of space
across two stories
the three existing function rooms within
the freight house will be retained and
modernized to accommodate
a wide variety of public and private
events including the installation of the
council chamber
the new extension will be modern a
flexible working environment
accommodating agile working practices
and providing a wide variety of
individual
and collaborative working environments
careful selection of materials high
levels of insulation
renewable sources of power heating and
ventilation and car charging points will
all ensure the building is constructed
and operated as environmentally
sustainably as possible
the project is an opportunity to create
a truly unique public building
for the communities of rochford and the
surrounding district
next slide please
a short walk from the freight house is
the site at 3 to 15 south street
the relocation of council services to
the freight house provides an
opportunity to undertake a development
at three to fifteen south street that
restores the existing historic buildings
and secures their future through
conversion back to residential use
next slide please
the regeneration of the site will
deliver high quality
and affordable housing that will support
and strengthen the wider town centre
community in rochford
the timing of the development will be
carefully programmed with the freight
house
to ensure council services continue to
be delivered safely
whilst also delivering housing that
meets local needs within a timely
fashion
in addition the development will retain
conserve and enhance the existing listed
buildings
and heritage assets on the site
next slide please
numbers three to fifteen form a
continuous frontage onto the east side
of south street
predominantly two and three stories in
height the buildings contribute strongly
to the character of the street
which is also in the rochford
conservation area
more modern late 20th century editions
that are one and two stories in height
are present to the rear
whilst the buildings along south street
form a continuous row
each plot is distinct in the way it
looks on to the street
which reflects their former uses as
individual houses
next slide please
the site includes four separately listed
grade
two buildings and is also adjacent to
the great two star listed 17 south
street
consequently we have focused on the
heritage of the site
and we have plotted the age and historic
significance of each building
within the site and its component parts
such as
internal walls staircases and character
features this has allowed us to
appreciate
which parts of the site are important
and must be retained and restored
and which parts can be removed or
adapted to accommodate the development
as well as this heritage understanding
our work also
includes the analysis of the wider site
and surrounding area
such as vehicular and pedestrian access
views into and from the site privacy of
neighbouring houses
and ecological and arboricultural
constraints
next slide please
the underlying principle of the
proposals is to restore and conserve the
listed buildings
and the elements of the site that
positively contribute to the
conservation area
this is achieved through their adaption
and reuse as residential apartments
our proposals include the removal of
less sensitive alterations
that date from the late 20th century
both internally
and with the removal of the modern
single-story extensions to the rear of
the site
using archival research the internal
rearrangement of the buildings will seek
to restore
historic room proportions reinstate
staircases and hallways
and re-establish active front doors onto
south street
next slide please
[Music]
removal of the poor quality 20th century
additions to the rear of the site
improves the setting of the historic
buildings the front onto south street
and allows for more residential and
visitor car parking on the site
private and shared amenity space is
provided and refuse and bicycle storage
the landscaped walled garden that spans
from the rear of number 11 south street
south to the rear of number 17 will be
retained
and preserved as a shared garden
the frontages onto south street will be
retained and relatively unaltered
existing historic windows doors facades
and details
will be restored pedestrian access will
be maintained by the existing
access route from south street between
numbers 7 and 9.
the existing vehicular access from the
east via millview meadows and millview
court
will also be retained
there is no new build development
proposed on the site at 3-15 south
street
more the careful and sensitive
conversion and adaption
of the existing buildings
next slide please
so in summary the outline proposals
provide twenty
one two and three bedroom apartments
thirty five percent of the dwellings
will be affordable on-site car parking
is provided for residents and visitors
and secure bicycle and motorbike is also
provided
the adaption of existing buildings to
accommodate new uses
is fundamentally sustainable when
compared to a whole site redevelopment
whilst the heritage significance of the
existing buildings and the wider
conservation
area will of course be respected and
prioritized
the selection of low carbon and low
energy materials
improvement of thermal insulation within
external walls and routes
use of renewable sources for heating and
where possible
solar panels to generate electricity on
site
will all contribute to an
environmentally and historically
sensitive
development next slide please
number 57 is located in a prominent
location
at the southern end of south street
opposite the busy junction with bradley
way
and south end road the site
and the existing building within it has
been vacant for many years
it is in close proximity to the river
roach and consequently
the site is within flood risk zone three
this means it is liable to flooding
next slide please
the objectives of the redevelopment of
57 south street
are to regenerate through residential
development providing housing that meets
local needs
the relay redevelopment must address and
deal with the flood risk
that presently restricts the way the
site can be used
next slide please
understanding the key opportunities and
constraints of the site
directly informs our outline proposals
the existing building is not listed but
the site is located within the rockford
conservation area
and as i've mentioned before adopts a
prominent gateway position to the town
the existing building is in a poor
condition and accommodates the southern
portion of the site
with the northern two-thirds being
predominantly left to
overgrown outstanding the site has an
existing vehicular access from south
street
and the site demise includes eight
parking spaces
accessed across the fire station iv
court indeed a number of these are in
use by ruptured fire station themselves
the trees to the rear boundary are in a
poor condition
and therefore their removal and
replacement through a suitable
replanting strategy would be beneficial
the site's surroundings combine a number
of different use classifications
with residential dwellings to the north
and northeast commercial uses to the
northwest
and the fire station and industrial
units to the south and east
next slide please
whilst options to restore and convert
number 57 south street have been
explored
the risk of flooding to the site
severely compromises the use of the
existing building
and therefore the viability of its
retention
the demolition of existing building will
allow a new residential development
that can address and overcome the flood
risk issues
despite its current condition we
appreciate that the existing building at
number 57 does contribute to the
character of the conservation area
therefore any replacements must be of a
very high quality
and appropriate and sensitive to its
surroundings with particular recognition
of the site's prominent location
the scheme will preserve the parking
capacity for the fire station
and provide residential and visitor car
parking spaces on site
some of these residential spaces are
under crop spaces
that are located at ground level beneath
the rear part of the building
next slide please
the outline scheme proposals include a
two-story development
to the north and east with rooms within
the sloping roof at second floor
a three-story element that draws
inspiration from the georgian and
victorian houses further north along
south street
articulates the corner of the site and
its prominence
on the street scene
next slide please
in summary the current proposals provide
eight
new residential dwellings at a mix of
one
and two bedroom apartments
the scheme responds to the flood risk
constraints on the site
by elevating the habitable ground floor
levels and keeping the actual footprint
of the building where it touches the
ground
as small as possible
bicycle and motorbike parking is
provided for both residents and visitors
the outline proposals for number 57
south street provide a development that
is an exemplar in the quality of both
internal accommodation
and external appearance that this
prominent gateway site
demands thank you
and back to you mike thank you peter
that was a very detailed presentation
with an awful lot of facts and figures
and information
that of course will be available after
this presentation for you to
reflect and look at and look at
particular points of interest to you
so thank you very much indeed peter i
are now going to
move on to the next part of the
presentation where we're going to
welcome both george and matt to deal
with various aspects
george will start with details of the
overall benefits of the asset delivery
program
and how the ongoing and updated
information can be viewed by the public
on both the rdc and voyage websites and
perhaps
most significantly how you the general
public
can personally engage in this process
matt will join him with any specific
details from an rdc's perspective
thanks
evening mike evening everyone if i may
just jump in there i'm going to lead
this part of the presentation actually
um
if i may thank you mike i'm sure george
will join us as we go through
that's absolutely fine thank you uh
evening everyone and um
thank you for joining us this evening
for the first webinar um
i'm going to touch on um three
three areas this evening as mike set out
so the benefits of the proposals
um some social value considerations and
also the next steps
and just starting um with benefits of
the proposal some of those
have been touched on already this
evening but i do want to
just go into a bit more depth on on this
um
in terms of those benefits um a key area
i'd like to touch on is financial
sustainability
um the council undertook a detailed
business case
some time ago and that demonstrated that
the proposed scheme
would be more cost efficient than
continuing to operate the existing
buildings in their current form
essentially due to their age their
layouts and the need for continued
investment to ensure they were
suitable for modern working practices
um ander actually touched on this in her
introduction
put simply considering the whole program
doing the minimum was more expensive in
the longer term
second thing i want to touch on
is one regarding improved community
facilities
it's a key message i think and i've seen
some
some messages coming on the chat
function we'll certainly pick up later
but it is a key
message to pick up the existing freight
house
will be refurbished to provide modern
high quality
community facilities for the whole
community and the wider district to
benefit from
this horrible agile modern space
it'll be flexible efficient space
enabling
civic meetings to be held but also
community
activities as they currently do it will
be an improved
refurbished facility um
the proposed new extension which peter
sets out in his presentation
that will provide the operational and
administrative services
ensuring that the workforce can operate
in a modern and efficient way
and continue to deliver the uh the
services i know that our residents rely
on
final point on this slide is regarding
the retention and restoration of
community assets and again it's
something peter touched on
in his presentation but it really is
important for us um
from members from office to the council
as a whole and i know from a community
perspective
it's something we do hear from the
community in terms of the importance of
these assets and their
and their uh their function as a whole
um so the program will see the retention
and restoration of the list of
properties uh within the rochester
conservation area
um and the poses will be sensitive to
the historical nature of the assets
um as an example to the rear of south
street
we're taking great care to retain the
historic walled garden
and the mature trees to the rivers
outside
at the freighthouse site we also want to
make more of the
fantastic green open space adjacent to
the windmill
and it provides an improved access to
that space from from the
refurbished freight house and new
extension
and we're also of course looking to
bring forward um the regeneration of the
vacant and quite constrained site
57 south street it's in a key position
in the town i feel um
as a project it's a key opportunity for
us to
us to bring that site forward as well
the development of the freight house as
i said will be sensitive and also be
sustainable
and it will deliver improved energy
performance and also reduce carbon
footprint
at the site in terms of the residential
developments and peters touched on some
of this
we will bring forward um high quality
sustainable town centre accommodation
and that will contribute to local
housing need including affordable and
social housing
meeting or over achieving on the
council's policy can i have the
next slide please
moving on to social value um it's been a
key theme
since the early part of the programme
essentially by social value this is how
we can
deliver wider social economic and
environmental benefits
through the program um and we set out
the importance of this right from the
early stage
uh the early stages of the program and
gb partnerships as our partner
have responded very positively to this
and i'm sure peter and george will come
in
later on the presentation to talk more
about it
when we talk about social value
essentially we're looking at
skills and employment for example um
bringing forward apprenticeships and
work placements
as a result of the developments we're
also considering our local supply chain
how do we source locally for example
we're also considering how we protect
the environment through sustainable
solutions and
energy efficient developments and
perhaps most ruling of all um
engaging local schools social
enterprises businesses and groups
to ensure they have an opportunity to
engage in the program
next slide please
so on the final slide from myself as
angela set out on her introduction
this is the pre-application engagement
process
and we want it to be meaningful and we
encourage residents to complete the
questionnaire questionnaire
via the link on the screen and also to
engage with the
q a session at the end of this webinar
the engagement survey is now live
and it runs till the 28th of feb
council wasn't set out how important
engagement was to the program and i
would certainly echo that
we do welcome your feedback and it will
help shape the program
i do hope the information has been
useful this evening um a priest there's
been quite a lot of information
certainly through peter's detailed
presentation we've tried to keep it
concise
uh but further information is available
on the voyage website i would encourage
everybody to
log on to that website and to check it
for further updates as the program
develops and evolves
mike that completes my presentation
thank you very much thank you matt
thank you very much indeed george did
you want to add anything from your
perspective to matt's presentation
thanks very much mike no i would just
emphasize the fact that
you know we are um really reaching out
to the community to
to gain their feedback and just i would
just like to encourage people to visit
the website and to comment
um because all comments will be uh read
and and thoughts will be incorporated
into the designs as we move forward
but other than that i'm happy to move on
to the
q a session george
thank you very much indeed um i hope
that you found all these presentations
very illuminating
and you may have a number of questions
don't forget
it is not too late to send in a question
even if we do not have
time tonight every question will receive
a response
and i'm sure that my fellow panelists
will be able to include
uh any questions that they've seen from
the chat functions while this
webinar has been in process i'm going to
go through the questions now
and invite one of my fellow panelists to
to respond
but equally any of the other panelists
who have some meaningful input
please feel free to join in so if we
look at the questions
that we've received so far to date i
noticed that a number
relate to car parking at the various
sites so let's start there
which is probably one for matt and
angela but others can respond as well
the general questions are along can you
please give
details of the electric car charging
points
at the residential sites will each
resident have their own
allocated space and perhaps this one's
for matt
will there be enough parking spaces for
staff and visitors
at the extended and refurbished freight
house
and will there be any cost thank you
i'm happy to come in first actually mike
um
angela mata a chance to gather their
thoughts on that one but
um as far as the car parking is
concerned then
we look to provide a minimum of one
space bird dwelling um
at 3 to 15 for example there are 24
spaces um for the 20 apartments
that peter itemized earlier at
number 57 then there are ten spaces for
the
for the eight apartments so you can see
that there there is
also some space for uh visitors as well
um do you want me to comment on the
electric vehicle
um charging provision
yes please uh george with with the rdc
officers unable to do so
uh as they wish yeah i think uh as far
as the electric
vehicle charging provision is concerned
then we
want to provide as much um charging
facilities as possible
um the biggest issue actually is is
where the supply to the site
is currently insufficient for all spaces
um over time clearly
that that situation will change as
electrical electric
vehicles become more popular um and i
think whilst we have the current
circumstances then
a reasonable um target is to
for us to provide um say 50
of these spaces um with with
charging points but what we would
definitely um do is to future proof
all of the locations by providing the
trunking to
to every space for later conversion
because you know that is where a lot of
the um cost actually comes
and a lot of the disruption in the
provision of
of the facilities at a later date
thank you george matt did you want to
comment on the specific question about
enough parking spaces for staff and
visitors at the freight house
yes thanks mike we'll do um i think it's
it's a it's a really good question and
parking is always uh
always top agenda when considering these
things i think um
considering the new ways of working as a
council we're looking at in terms of
more
more agile flexible working that many
people obviously are looking at
currently even before covid
we will have less staff on site we're
working more flexibly more agile way
so at any one time there'll be less
staff on site because more will be
working
in a more flexible way so there will be
less staff parking essentially at the
site
but other analysis has shown that there
is
capacity at backup park for um
to enable us to continue for our
community use and our staffing use
at that site um so i think we can be uh
we can be confident there is
plentiful supply for community use at
the site to continue
thank you matt okay well let's cover
that one moving on to the next question
then
one close to my heart which is heritage
related is perhaps that one that peter
can start off with a response
and the questions i merge into to one
please
will the existing external appearance of
three to fifteen south street
be maintained will this be a high
quality development
and will residents have any outside
space and secondly
and i know this was mentioned in the
presentation but i'll mention it anyway
secondly why are you building flats 57
south street
on a flood zone peter can you start
please
yes uh thanks mike so firstly on on
three to fifteen
uh the question about external
appearance um
as i said in the presentation the the
external appearance of three to fifteen
particularly
the elevation that fronts onto south
street um
is considered highly significant both
because it
um is is the elevations of a number of
listed buildings
uh four four of those buildings are
listed um
but in addition it it characterizes that
part of south street and
contributes to the character of the
conservation area um
as a consequence changes to that front
elevation will be
extremely minimal um if anything the
changes will be simply to restore
where there are potential sort of
defects in the condition
such as um repairing of window frames um
restoring and repairing uh fascia boards
and roof details and so on
um so actual any any sort of changes to
that front elevation will be
as i say extremely minimal the changes
to the development to the rear are more
substantial
however um they purely relate to the
20th century
infill that sits between two
two-story elements at the back that is
um partly the porter cabin
um reception area that that angela
mentioned earlier uh and also
um in between the port cabin and the the
rear
uh elevation of the listed buildings is
a separate single story extension as
well
the proposals are to remove both of
those and
um with uh input from our heritage
consultants and also
um conversations with um the
conservation officer on behalf of
rochester district council and essex
county council
that removal is supported as being an
enhancement of the setting of the list
of buildings
so hopefully that reassures you that um
certainly the the elevations on to south
street will remain as they stand indeed
they'll be
they'll be improved through careful
restoration of the key elements of those
elevations
and then sorry mike don't you carry on
um i think that was the main question
for 3-15
was there a follow-up for 3-15 i know we
can move to 57.
not not unless any of our rdc colleagues
want to add any
input from their perspective mike could
i just uh could i just add the
george on each of the each and every
site we
do have done a full heritage assessment
um
and and commissioned a uh an independent
report
and it's on that that we then base and
peter
and his colleagues base their designs
and and those designs are then
[Music]
consulted upon which is what we're going
through at the moment and consulted with
the council's advisors
so recently peter had a a walk around of
3 to 15 in particular and there was um
identified a a stairwell that was of
a note from a heritage perspective and
therefore that
is being retained so you know this is
this is how the designs evolve really
and and take into account all of the
heritage aspects
thank you george thank you if we can now
move on please i have a number of
questions as they specifically relate to
the freight house please
uh possibly for peter and matt to answer
and
any other colleagues as appropriate
specific questions have been
include what will the floor area be
will public events still be held there
what is the capacity and flexibility
within the premises
another question was there is a current
issue with the acoustics the poor
acoustics in the freight house
will that be improved with the new build
and finally another specific question
from one of the attendees this evening
i attend a weekly yoga class and i
understand there are no
plans for the resumption of sessions
irrespective of changes in lockdown
arrangements
why can classes not be run
who wants to start off with that so i'll
start mike if i may
and then i'm sure peter might jump in um
as we go through
i mean just to reassure um uh
residents and every listing this evening
as i said earlier the
the community spaces we currently have
will be retained and will be refurbished
and improved and will be
available to be hired that's
fundamentally what will happen
um and that's a really important message
um
so when we're looking at and peter will
confirm sort of
layout specifically but the proposals
we've shown and
they're still being developed but um for
example the great eastern room
um in broad terms will remain as it is
in terms of its its size its broad size
its capacity um so absolutely those
those events
continue that yoga class was mentioned
can continue the other sessions could
continue
but more than that i think it will be an
improved refurbished space
um is what we'll be looking at we'll be
investing into that building
for the community essentially um
acoustics was mentioned
um having been the the uh
the facility a number of times myself
i'm aware the great eastern room
is challenging from an acoustic
perspective that was in the brief right
from an early stage working with george
and peter and colleagues
to have to look at how we combat that so
again how can we encourage
even greater use through an improved
acoustic solution so yes
absolutely that's being considered but
fundamentally my perspective key message
for myself is yes it's available for the
community
um we're going to refurbish it it'll be
available for use and we absolutely um
welcome and the community to continue
using that building in a much
much better offer refurbished facility
and peter did you want to
add anything further to that yes i can
do thanks man
just to be a little more specific really
an ad detail to that
so um the area sort of floor area of the
freight house
as it currently stands as the existing
building is is 980 square meters
um the area of the new build that we're
adding
um and this is the total area both the
ground and first floors added together
so
what's called the gross internal area is
830 square meters so the total area of
the building will become
just over 1800 square meters in size
um the the area of the function spaces
within the freight house will not
change so so the the footprints of
the great eastern room um and the two
smaller function rooms
um the one at first floor up on the
mezzanine and
um the smaller room that's at the
southern end of the freight house
or towards the southern end they're all
remaining as as the existing area that
they are
um so in terms of capacity uh there is
there is no loss or detriment to the
capacity of those rooms
um but the refurbishment does give us
the opportunity to improve the quality
of those rooms
it also offers us the opportunity to
improve the accessibility of those rooms
so that they can be accessed
independently um they can have their own
access to supplementary spaces
and improved kitchen and catering spaces
but the key point about acoustics is a
really good one
and it does pose a challenge to us as
designers um
the building is is a valuable piece of
of industrial heritage and and part of
understanding that heritage is that
is the quality of the space inside the
finishes of the interior walls which is
fair face brickwork
and the visibility and openness of the
roof space above
and whilst that gives a great character
to the space and allows us to understand
the history of the building
it does pose some challenges in terms of
acoustics so what we need to do is think
about how can we retain the
the quality and the character of the
space but create a
a space that is acoustic dream versatile
that accommodates a number of different
functions from music
speech drama sports um
you know all the different things that
might happen in there and each of those
have slightly different acoustic
requirements
so the strategy at the moment is to um
include an acoustic improvement
that also in includes um the thermal
improvement of the building and that's
largely looking at the roof
still retaining the openness and the
visibility of the of the trusses that
are there that's very much a part of the
um the uh character of the space
but in between those trusses lining the
underside of the roof to allow us to
improve the
insulation and keep heat within the
building and allow the space to be
heated efficiently and the environment
to be comfortable
but also to apply absorbency within
those that lining
so that the reverberation of sound
within that room
um and within the other rooms can be can
be managed um
there's also obviously proposals um for
when the
room is converted into a council chamber
and any other
um spaces or uses of the space that
require acoustic enhancement
then obviously audio visual equipment
can be provided
which obviously will enhance the use of
speech within the space
so hopefully that provides you with a
bit of detail peter thank you for that
detailed response
i'm conscious of time but i'm also
conscious that i've got four
very important questions i'd like to try
and cover if i possibly can please
so if the panelists can give uh brief
responses to the following
uh moving on to a very important
question regarding the environment
please
perhaps this is something that both
angela and george can have a
response to environmental sustainability
is one of the key elements
to any and all large-scale projects such
as this
what are the initial and ongoing
environmental benefits
that this project will deliver
who wants to start do you want do you
want to go first
angela or or would you like to thank
george i was just i'll talk sort of in
the in the
uh in the general perhaps you can pick
up any specifics
it was really important for us that um
we built in environmental issues from
the get-go
it was one of the key issues that we
tested throughout the procurement
process
the council has a commitment to carbon
neutrality
and we also recognize the importance of
environmental sustainability
for creating a future legacy of of the
council so it made sense to make sure
that those environmental concerns were
built in from the beginning and whether
that's in relation to
materials um and also that will
deliver environmental sustainability in
terms of
maintenance and repair as well as in the
operational state and through to things
as you've already heard
from from peter in relation to solar
panels
and uh um electric vehicle charging
points
so george yeah on the on on the
specifics i mean
next month we'll have a chance to talk
more about the proposals for the
mill community center where we've got an
excellent opportunity to
um create an exemplar um sustainable
building
um from scratch but there are more
challenges
sometimes with um converting
existing buildings especially um listed
buildings
but we take each site on a case-by-case
basis
and provide a sustainability strategy
for each of the sites
and clearly we're moving towards low
carbon
fuels with electricity as the
primary fuel source um i i
won't bore you too much with the details
and mike is keen to
move us along but what we're talking
about are
um air source heat pumps um feeding
radiators or
or underfloor heating um together with a
mechanical ventilation we would also be
looking at solar panels where possible
um without again disrupting the um
the roof line so for example at 3 to 15
then you wouldn't see the solar panels
if
if they were visible from the street we
wouldn't be putting them up
um so so um that's probably the um
all that i need to say is it's a right
at the top of the agenda
um and we will be introducing the best
uh sustainable solution um in each case
okay thank you george anybody else want
to add anything on that
moving on then you must expect a coveyed
related question so here it is
perhaps matt and george and angela will
have an input on this particular one
has covid affected this program what
changes have been made since inception
and are
your time scales achievable and
realistic
subject to formal planning agreement
when do you propose to start work on the
south street
and freight house developments and how
do you plan to mitigate
any disruption during the building works
who wants to start
your actually you go first well i was
going to say i touched on the covid
piece and then perhaps
george you can pick up the the details
of the programme
um of course uh kovid has um taken
everybody
by surprise um this past year
and so we clearly have learned lessons
um
from our uh virtual working environment
that we are operating at present
but it's fair to say that the uh
constraints and the restraints within
which we're working at the moment are
not
at all how we would uh wish to work but
nonetheless um one of the
uh guiding features for the floor plate
of the extension to the freight house
was in relation to the number of
um council offices that would need to be
accommodated and that includes not just
working stations but also meeting rooms
collaboration spaces interview rooms and
places for the public to
to meet with officers and we knew that
um the work that we had done uh in
relation to our
accommodation at south street was that
we were over provisioned
so we have gone from a a a
ratio of essentially essentially 11
desks or desk spaces
to every 10 employees to one where we're
looking at seven for every 10 employees
and we're encouraging our
staff to operate a mobile and flexible
agile working policy which enables them
to connect
um from home and from other places where
they can touch
down and one of the one of those key
places will be
the new community center in rayleigh so
it gives
enables a peripatetic workforce and many
of our
employees are out in the district
working with
residents and with businesses and so
work is is something that you do rather
than somewhere that you go
we are keeping that under review in
terms of uh co-vid
and how that will operate um and the
lessons that we've learned in in terms
of of how well-equipped we are to to
manage that
and so we have an a a transformation
program a digital transformation program
which is running alongside this asset
delivery program
which will enable digital technology to
assist officers and members to
respond to an agile working environment
george um excuse me um
i think that covid the impact has been
one of a
massive challenge to the program rather
than a delay to the programme
and um we've all had to
adapt to a new way of working and indeed
not just working forming a partnership
um
through virtual media rather than um
across the table which would be more
normal in
this sort of program um but with
you know a lot of effort and goodwill
then we have remained
on track and on programme over the last
12 months um i think that
specifically we've recognized the
challenges
in operating the current um mill arts
and entertainment center for example
which means it it lays dormant albeit
that is used as a
being used as a vaccination uh center at
the moment
and and what we have agreed with the
council is to
bring forward that um that particular
part of the
of the program by nine months um
so so assuming we can manage to do that
then then that will be a success and
um so all of that being said there are
many challenges ahead for
for the all of us um but we've got every
intention of
of um remaining firmly on track and on
programme
george thanks very much indeed well
there were some other parts of the
question though mike one there i'd uh
um i can't recall it all um it was a
case of subject to formal planning
agreement when did you propose to start
work on the south street and freight
house developments
okay so um so the intention on the
current program um for 57 south street
for 19 south street for
um freight house and pacific suite is to
commence construction in the last in the
final quarter of
of this year um the the exception to
that is 3 to 15
south street because that is the one
that will be occupied
will continue to be occupied by the
council whilst the new freight house
is is delivered the freight house itself
will take approximately 12 months
at which time the cancer the council
will decant into the new freight house
and we will commence the work on 3 to
15. thank you just very briefly the
other point was
how do you plan to mitigate any possible
disruption
during the building works
[Music]
um i mean where that where there's
potential for disruption for
example the uh the mill then
um we're very um aware that there is
ongoing activity for example
um for people using the windmill and we
will
um you know uh make sure that that that
activity can
can proceed as normal i'm fairly certain
that would be a question raised at the
next webinar
in uh in march george um i know we're
running slightly over time but i hope
you'll give me permission
i do have one final very important
question if i can please
and we haven't yet mentioned the most
important aspect of any project
which are the financials this one is
possibly for angela and other colleagues
but
what impact will the overall cost of the
project
have on the council finances how much
will this project cost
and how will it be repaid that's a good
one who wants to take that one then
angela
i think that's me so um so mike you'll
appreciate that there is quite a lot of
detailed um calculations that sit behind
this and that's in our outline business
case
which is published and freely available
for those people who
who want to get involved in in the level
of detail but it's to remind
people that the program is cross-funded
so in other words the receipts obtained
from the development of the sites
funds the additional work that is done
at the freight house with some
additional injection of capital
um for the mill hall new community
center
um as things currently stand and i am
talking in sort of round numbers because
again as you will appreciate we um are
not yet
at that stage where we have a finite
cost model because we're still at these
early engagement
steps the additional net
contribution from the council is 1.5
million
pounds in the region of 1.5 million
pounds and that some
is exclusively uh as a result of the
additionality
of the uh enhanced mill site
um the savings that um that
that the council will make by achieving
this program is
uh approximately 250 000 pounds a year
and um so that makes for a payback
period of about six years
um uh in terms of a payment by the
council
so the council would expect to see its
uh net revenue budget um
therefore not impacted if we were not
doing this program
we would expect to see our net revenue
budget increase
by 250 000 pounds per year
um and um the the fund for the uh
the capital sum um is to as things
currently stand
uh projected to be um paid from
our um reserves but we have calculated
our business case on the premise that if
we had to
fund price fund from the public works
loan board
that we could in fact do so so it is a
very much a worst case scenario
angela thank you very much indeed well
i'm afraid to say that time has beaten
us
and if my phone would stop ringing and
i'll i'll bring the meeting to a close
before i finally pass on to councillor
wooden to
uh to say the final few words i do hope
that you found this uh
webinar very interesting and informative
there's been an awful lot of information
which you'll take time to digest
can i please remind everybody that it's
not too late
to have your views your questions and
your observations
on any aspect of this over massive
undertaking
your voice will be heard and your
question will be dealt with
please try and attend the webinar
dealing with the proposals for rayleigh
on the 17th of march
and and help make your contributions
ahead of the final decisions
for my part i'd just like to thank all
the panelists to paul wilkins and
colleagues and from azure marketing
to nicki dawn and others at both rdc and
gb partnerships
who've helped in the background to this
evening's event um
so thank you very much indeed and i'll
let uh councillor simon wooten have the
last word
thank you thank you indeed
mike and thank you also to all my
colleague
panelists um certainly you seem to be an
extremely popular man tonight because uh
your phone uh is obviously uh uh
red hot with someone uh trying to get
hold of you
um but thank you indeed you've done an
absolutely superb job because it's not
the easiest environment
in which to capture questions which have
been submitted beforehand
and during the webinar itself it is
difficult
but what i would like to say is those
questions have been captured as we're
going along
i've picked up a few notes myself that
uh there's a little bit frustration that
some of them haven't been directly
answered
but they will be captured they will be
answered
and the answers will appear on the
voyage website so
because i think there's a number of key
key points there
so thank you to
everyone who has taken time out tonight
to the wider audience
for attending and the valuable
contribution your interest really is
appreciated uh there's certainly food
for thought
tonight uh a number of points have been
raised which uh
to be fair have been discussed in the
past but it's
interesting to see that uh your focus is
our focus as well from the point of view
of
rockford council the webinar is now
going to be shared
and ongoing feedback continues to be
welcomed
and that is done via the voyage website
or
alternatively you can write to uh voyage
at the council offices in south street
in the usual way you would
send a letter or contact the uh the
council
so it just remains for me to remind you
that
17th of march is the next
one of these webinars um i think it's
gone extremely well tonight
but certainly possibly we can learn uh
lessons on how to make it work even
better on the 17th of march
and thank you very much indeed to
everyone
and have a good rest of your evening
thank you very much indeed
bye